it is 6 25 on your monday morning man
what a difference
a year makes i hope that pedestrian
bridge grand opening we showed last week
in the southwest valley might have at
least sounded
vaguely familiar because we featured the
groundbreaking for that project here on
what's driving me crazy in march of last
year
gonna make it easier to get to and from
desert oasis
to the residential neighborhoods nearby
without having to go up
rainbow over to cactus and then around
so the pedestrian bridge it's going in
on rainbow just south of erie
will cross over the union pacific
railroad tracks onto or near the school
property
well it sure was windy last thursday
when commissioner jones and staff and
students from desert oasis were the
first
ones to walk across that pedestrian
bridge
commissioner justin jones of course with
that bridge the far
southwest and the far northwest may
eventually
link up to close the loop on what's
called the vegas valley
rim trail where bicyclists and walkers
be able to cover a giant track around
most of urbanized southern nevada as we
know it today
got all this information on our website
8newsnow.com click traffic and what's
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic eight
eight newsnow.com